movie fans everywhere are talking about
Marvel's Merc with the mouth after the
success of Deadpool's opening weekend
I'm Dave and welcome to your fourth wall
breaking GS news updates Fox's new
Deadpool movie continues to break
records after becoming the top Thursday
night u.s. opening for an r-rated movie
the film has now posted the biggest
opening day in February history taking
in 47 point five million dollars for its
official - best ik opening on Friday it
added another forty 1.8 million on
Saturday bringing its three day holds
135 million dollars this according to a
report from Hollywood news site deadline
Deadpool is now the second biggest debut
in US history for the first installment
of a superhero film it's only behind the
Avengers which made 207 point four
million dollars during its opening in
2012 rounding out the top five our Man
of Steel at 116 point six million Spider
Man with a hundred and fourteen point
eight million and Iron Man at ninety
eight point six million the Ryan
Reynolds over-the-top action movie could
bring in more than 150 million dollars
for the four-day Presidents Day weekend
this would easily surpass the current
record holder 2015's Fifty Shades of
Grey which made 93 million dollars over
the weekend last year internationally
Deadpool is also performing well The
Hollywood Reporter says it can make more
than 80 million dollars overseas this
weekend boosting as global figures even
higher
Deadpool had a reported production
budget of just fifty eight million
dollars and supposedly a sequel is
already being planned
so if you see Marvel's new antihero
movie let us know what you thought of it
in the comments section below and for
more on Deadpool and all things super
stay tuned to games.com
[Music]